[Music]
in spoiled brat news submitted by
peekaboo [ __ ] hey what do you really
mean though I don't know what do you
want it to mean
I don't know he handles eyebrow like
there is another meaning because always
some sexual innuendo that's going on
that's I just said the words but the
eyebrow said way mortgage was twas y'all
that made that connection a man pushed
his BMW into the river because it wasn't
the birthday gift he was hoping for
Oh are you make another roll in the wall
Joe control Joe starts to get off
control [ __ ] so even like his the back
of his hair he went from my soul to go
and I brought it back down move sideways
will you do that so you can see what I'm
talking about
[Laughter]
alright so those guys a 22 year old man
no 22 year old shift [ __ ] brat 22 year
old man just kidding alright so he drove
his brand-new BMW 3-series sedan into a
canal after so they're reporting that he
was really a sec he wanted a Jaguar
instead of I know that feeling
what's a [ __ ] Jaguar over the
ultimate driving machine come on what is
this piece the bottom bottom level if
it's a thief I could have been an m3
well ok ok that's ok but what kind of
Jaguar was before they look too basic to
me like um like they looked like Honda's
or whatever like to me I was like a not
car person I'm just like I could not
point out a BMW are you do because
you're an odd car person yeah what it's
in abundance is what you're saying
they're the ass holiest drivers for the
for sure every time we get cut off its
oh my had once I'm gonna defend it
[ __ ] ease
all right so this dude he's from India
by the way this is a photo Oh oh it's
not an m3 who got it for him he's got a
lot of Troy yeah Darren's got him this
car and they're reporting it that Hugh
is just so upset because it's not what
he for his birthday it's a birthday gift
and he ended up just driving it into
this canal and they're reporting that he
even took a video of it and send it to
his parents I wonder how he got out of
the car like he [ __ ] drove it in she
opened the door swam out and enclosed it
yeah cuz it is plugged what the trunk is
open so he's like joven he's like holy
[ __ ] I can't get out maybe that's why I
kept this raft it is like a rock in
there because the trunks wide [ __ ]
open right yeah I wasn't saying it is
like a baby gonna I don't want it yeah
[ __ ] throwing their toy into the fire
like take it yes so they were reporting
that the parents sold this Toyota car in
order to get him this Beamer also don't
even rich so that's what they're
reporting
I sold the clothes off our back we saw
our old car we saw everything
I blame the parents then yeah for
raising a little [ __ ] here I blame the
parents for not getting the right car
it's like Eric Cartman's mom yeah
there's an episode where he didn't get
an iPhone he got an Android yeah [ __ ]
piss yeah that also does mean though the
parents weren't listening to yes cuz I
so they have the money to buy a job
alright yeah because they bought a BMW
yeah so it's roughly in the same range
or whatever and assuming that this kid
has been going I wanted yeah I warned ya
yes he's entitled
yes he's spoiled but if your kid has
also been screaming the brand that he
wants and you have the money to afford
it and you're gonna do it but you buy
something else I can see why the kids
also pissed it probably did their
research in like well this was the
better car and it's even more expensive
so like chillin it better
now mommy it's size these parents did
that with his sister his sister asked
for this doll when she was growing up
and I guess it was like this popular
doll that everybody had and it was a
very specific doll and the parents
bought her a one that cost twice as much
that's cause the better doll but I bet
she's pissed off she was pissed because
not the one she wanted and then she
never asked for anything because they're
not loving the way that kid wants to be
loved they're loving the way they want
to love them dude is in the right I had
a rich friend and I thought she was a
little [ __ ] because her parents bought
her [ __ ] m3 BMW Wow but she wanted a
Honda Civic what she wanted a Honda
Civic less than that you're sure he
dreamed of how she was gonna she was
gonna [ __ ] like add all those little
things to it and it doesn't look the
same with the with the BMW it doesn't
really you don't really put a bunch of
[ __ ] on it being done yeah but I still
thinks you a spoiled piece of [ __ ] cuz
I'm like you could totally sell that car
and buy like five six yeah and by the
Civic and have extra cash like through
the same thing man saw the car even
donated the car but but I know that
feeling though oh you didn't get what
you wanted because they were listening
alright I don't hate him anymore
you had or experience that you'd be that
kid oh we don't know the kids history
you might have been growing up next his
canal so he threw his GI Joe figurines
in the canal then he threw a bike in the
canal and the skateboarding that he's
been telling his parents if you don't
buy the [ __ ] that I want it's going in
the [ __ ] now you need to move
yeah it's super the real estate shipping
as well okay I bet there's a lot of dope
[ __ ] in that canal the reality is it's a
wishing well and people been throwing
some three pennies in there saying I
want to BMW and it's just floating down
the street
[Laughter]
alright so the family they're reporting
that they own 25 acres of agricultural
land either real estates cheap or will
it sold a piece of land a few months ago
and that seems to be how they got the
money for this okay but the dad is
denying the reports he's saying that his
son never demanded a Jaguar he he was
driving and so he ended up in the canal
because he was trying to avoid hitting
an antelope on the road oh my god I was
picturing a water buffalo and they're
also saying that he suffers from some
sort of like mental health condition is
that him influenza yeah so he got he got
in a dumb car accident and tried to act
like he was mad about the car I don't
even know how or the dads want to get
their sons back and I have a not a face
yes son doesn't seem like a spoiled brat
maybe yeah cuz I don't even know how
they got the initial reports of him
wanting a Jaguar I don't even know like
why that's in the report is the son
actually said that actually I wanted a
Jag like the [ __ ] the quarters come
yeah I think it is a little saving face
thing because they were mentioning that
there's a video too that they sent the
parents so I'm like how do you know all
of this see I think the dads in denial
and denial is not just a river in Egypt
then I it's the river in India you say
dude that's [ __ ] crazy man yeah
that's insane
so they are like wealthy then because
also I think they have the luxury tanks
out there where the cars don't cost the
same as here it's like double yeah yeah
they have that India I think so so like
well I mean they have the foreign tax
and all that stuff so the BMW might be
like way more [ __ ] expensive than
what we get it for I remember when I was
like I don't know like eight or
something and I really wanted a ninja
turtle and then I wanted a Michelangelo
or Leonardo and then I got Dan
Donatello which is the nerd one worst
one yeah color is that one
that's the wackest one like I'd be happy
if it was just three Ninja Turtles I
don't even need the fourth one and your
parents are like what's the difference
between what do you do yeah but I was so
focused cuz I always had to be April
because she's the only girl I know it's
because I wanted to be a ninja troll and
I wanted to be specifically Leonardo but
then I could had to be the purple one if
I was gonna be ninjas her like if that
one of the guys were missing from the
group yeah yeah no one wanted to be that
one I'm either April or frickin
Donatello April figurines - yeah they
had eight figurines we will watch the
show and then we got to pick what
character we belong in the pretend yeah
so on Captain Planet
I picked water and like we would have
Ring Pop so we'd be like there was a
useless one two useless [ __ ] I
thought he was a girl it took me a while
to be like that's a boy like how is it I
thought it was a girl it looked like
Dora the Explorer Native American boy a
Indian with the bull cut I think you
forgot don't some [ __ ] useless ass
Power Man I liked water cuz she had
dolphins Captain Planet he's a hero to
zero no there's a cartoon with a good
message
it sounds great he got together in pop
pollution sounds awesome never [ __ ]
watched it their forces combined created
summon Captain Planet you were watching
scooby-doo huh i watch scooby-doo yeah
that's good messages in now on huh yeah
those pesky kids that would no one
wanted to be Velma relates with them
I don't know now it feels like the one
that nobody wanted to be is like the
majority yeah that's true
like now everyone's the Donatello
Donatello cool one right everybody wants
to be the computer hacker rather than
the [ __ ] cheerleader yeah that's true
everyone wants to be a shaggy now shaggy
can do what he wants legally now Scooby
Snacks for all hey but anyway so this
story here to me I'm like alright so
which one is it is it the fact that he
wanted the Jaguar yes or is it the fact
that he just has mental issues and the
dad
I think anyone Susanne he wanted the
Jaguar yeah cuz I mean that's pretty
extreme like destroying a whole entire
new car into a come out like I'm pretty
[ __ ] crazy and I won't do it several
hours to get this car out mm me like he
wanted a boat Oh what if he just I
wanted a kayak you've got me he's out
there trying to ride no that's a lot of
trunks open cuz he was like dude I don't
know any crazy ass like spoiled kids now
that that are dis crazy tyka he put his
toys in the fire because he didn't want
to
this is food and throws on the floor so
ungrateful yeah yeah every good hands
are always like that man I always they
don't understand gratitude mm-hmm
so I could already see how he is 26
that's why you got to make your kids
grow their own food
[Music]